opération spectaculaire dans le loir et
cher pour que le monter une gigantesque
fuite de gaz l'opération est toujours en
cours
chômage tassement confirmé en nous le
ministre du travail jean pierre soisson
en direct tout à l'heure l'union
soviétique d'accord avec les états unis
pour cesser de produire des armes
chimiques
après aussi pour réduire les stocks des
écus pour l'est la communauté européenne
renforce son aide financière à la
pologne et à la hongrie
des précisions de jacques delors en
direct de bruxelles tout à l'heure
madame monsieur bonsoir on dirait de la
science fiction
d'abord à cause du bruit le bruit
strident du gaz qui sifflent sous la
pression et qui fusent à plus de 40
mètres de haut
et puis le déploiement de ces machines
gigantesques que contrôles sains comme
c'est comme seul sur la plateforme
d'opérations à chémery dans le
loir-et-cher les techniciens essaient
depuis ce matin de stopper la plus
grosse fuite de gaz naturel qui se soit
jamais produit en france
une fuite sans danger toxiques affirme
depuis hier soir la préfecture même si
un important dispositif de secours est
déployé à l'arrière sur place pascal
deschamps et jean françois bernigaud
autour du puits numéro 13 à quelques
centimètres seulement d'un puissant
geyser de garde
5 silhouette s'affairent depuis près de
des pompiers voile en américain et trois
techniciens français confronté pour la
première fois à ce type d'accidents
à leur tête tu en bordel filmer ce matin
avant son départ sur le site
venu spécialement du texas il dirige la
ride control à houston wide web en
anglais c'est le puits en éruption
y at-il un risque est ce une opération
dangereuse pour vous il ya toujours un
risque mais cette fois je pense que cela
devrait bien se passer
jordan et son équipe devaient d'abord
resserrer le tuyau au moyen d'une pince
puissante puis percée pour injecter des
billes d'acier et de la boue afin de
colmater la fuite
opération délicate qui n'est pas encore
entré dans sa phase finale
car c'est alors que la pression du gal
risque de déformer le tuyau on devrait
constater une disparition du dard et de
la vitesse qu'on entend juste
pratiquement une extraction coop est
divine gaz alors ensuite l'opération
sera en l'ati morizet la boue au lieu de
suivre le chemin du gaz le score étant
stoppés commencera redescendre dans le
puits repousser le gardien réservoir et
on a donc à engager de l'ordre de 30
mètres cubes de l'ensemble du puits
jusqu'à moins aux 100 m si danger il y a
il reste donc limitée à la zone
d'intervention seule nuisance pour
l'environnement à deux kilomètres à la
ronde
un bruit assourdissant qui continuent
d'envahir le site comme un avion qui
n'en finirait pas de décoller plusieurs
dizaines de millions de mètres cubes de
gaz se sont échappés depuis hier matin
et gaz de france se refuse pour le
moment à chiffrer
de l'accident oui j'apprends à l'instant
que le gaz continuent de fuir mais on
apprend ainsi aussi que gaz de france
dispose chez bree les plus grands
bassins de stockage souterrain du monde
une sorte de réservoir artificiel qui
contient lui seul 10% de la consommation
annuelle de gaz en france
les explications de patrick esther on
brûle trois fois plus de gaz au mois de
janvier qu'au mois d'août
d'où la nécessité de stocker de
gigantesques volume en été pour pouvoir
faire face à la consommation
la solution emmagasiner le gaz naturel
en sous sol pratiquement rien de visible
à la surface quelques pompes quelques
vannes sur la douzaine de sites
existants chémery est le plus important
avec une capacité de 3 milliards de
mètres cubes
un forage réalisés jusqu'à une
profondeur de 11 100 m à travers des
structures géologiques adapté permet
d'atteindre une poche d'eau emprisonné
sous une couche d'argile imperméable 250
mètres d'épaisseur en marron sur notre
animation l'injection de gaz sous très
forte pression chasse l'eau le gaz du
méthane en général va pouvoir rester là
pendant plusieurs mois entre les roches
lorsque le besoin s'en fait sentir
la vanne de surface est ouverte le gaz
se détend remonte par le forage pour
être redistribués par le réseau en hiver
ic en tout cas à chémery où la
population vaque tranquillement ses
occupations
pierre joxe at-il ou non décidé de
rouvrir les hostilités avec charles
pasqua
le terrain choisi marécageux celui de la
sphère du carrefour du développement
une vieille affaire vous en souvenez
celle entre autres du vrai faux
passeport d'yves chalier le secret
défense invoquée par le précédent
ministre de l'intérieur couvrons think i
joueront les dossiers réponse des
etats-unis alors va-t-il être percé ce
secret défense qui entoure le fameux
vrai-faux passeport établi au nom de
navarro il avait permis à yves chalier
de se réfugier au brésil chalier ex chef
de cabinet nucci ancien ministre la
coopération pas question d'en savoir
plus
ces couverts par le secret défense avait
dit ce jour là charles pasqua
un mois plus tard son successeur pierre
joxe affirmé la défense n'a rien à voir
là dedans
fort de cette parole le juge jane avait
alors interrogé par écrit l'actuel
ministre l'intérieur
vous est il enfin le lever ce secret
demandé le magistrat qui a donné lors de
confectionner le passeport aime-t-il
bien la dst
il y à quelques trois semaines pierre
joxe répondait point par point mais
semble-t-il sans donner l'autorisation
magistrat d'aller enquêter ici à la dst
pierre joxe aurait dénoncé l'utilisation
abusive selon lui du secret qui entoure
la faire mais il ne serait pas allé plus
loin
autrement dit c'est maintenant la
discrétion qui succède au secret
toujours pas de preuves sur la nature
exacte de l'explosif utilisé pour
détruire le dc10 d'uta il ya tout juste
une semaine
le laboratoire central qui poursuit ses
analyses ne confirme aucune des rumeurs
qui font état de centex cet explosif
tchèque qu'affectionnent les terroristes
du moyen-orient bruno gex c'est ici au
laboratoire central de la préfecture que
les hommes de la police scientifique
analyse les premiers débris du dc 10
d'uta
il est encore trop tôt pour déterminer
avec certitude le type d'explosif
utilisé lors de l'attentât le semtex
tous les enquêteurs y ont pensé
cette pâte malléable de couleur ocre de
fabrication tchécoslovaque l'explosif
favori des terroristes c'est kg de
semtex ont été saisis par la police aux
irlandais de l'ira
les américains l'avaient mise en
évidence après la catastrophe de la
panam à lockerbie attentats imputés au
commandement général fplp dames et
djibrine on le voit les utilisateurs du
semtex sont multiples difficile dans ces
conditions de désigner avec certitude
l'auteur de l'attentât du dc-10
l'attention des enquêteurs doit aussi se
concentrer sur le dispositif de mise à
feu moyen plus sûr et plus efficace d'y
trouver là une signature ut à la
compagnie aérienne s'est constituée
partie civile pour avoir un accès à
l'enquêté judiciaire
le chômage légèrement fléchi le mois
dernier - 0,6 pour cent ce qui met le
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi à deux
millions cinq cent trente et un mille
six cents l'orientation à la baisse se
confirme donc sauf chez les femmes mais
la tendance reste lente et irrégulière
jean pierre soisson bon soit le voilà
alors est-ce que vous n'êtes pas un peu
à peu déçu malgré la tendance qui se
confirme de constater quand même que
malgré la croissance
l'augmentation est l'augmentation des
amp ont gelé poche de chômage ne sont
toujours pas en voie d'être résorbée il
ya une baisse
quand même importante sur l'année
puisqu'elles
ici à près de cinquante mille chômeurs
de moins et effectivement cette baisse
est lente et ms est irrégulière ce que
nous constatons dans les derniers six
c'est que le nombre
les entrées au chômage diminue et
diminue de façon importante plus de 10%
en un an les licenciements économiques
9%
c'est significatif d'une bonne santé de
la bonne santé retrouvée et ont constaté
thomas est sorti du chômage elles
n'augmentent et l'on voit au contraire
la situation s'aggrave et d'un certain
nombre de chauffeurs fenoyl de longue
durée de femmes
quand vous l'avez sous une forme de rage
et qui retrouve difficilement et du
travail et donc la politique du
gouvernement menée 17
complètement
super internet un certain nombre
d'autres meurent de retrouver à six mois
et donc développer la lutte contre
l'exclusion donc le sens du plan que
vous avez présenté il y à il y a dix
jours le conflit peut jour jean pierre
soisson pourquoi il n'y at il aucune
initiative du gouvernement pourquoi
restez-vous les bras croisés en quelque
sorte non il faut bien voir quel est le
et quel peut être le rôle du ministre du
travail dans cette affaire le rôle du
gouvernement dr
il est d'abord de veiller au respect des
règles qui régissent les relations
collectives au sein de l'entreprise
ces règles concernent notamment le la
mission des représentants du personnel
le recours au travail temporaire le
respect du droit de grève
et comme istres les salariés je suis
attentif au respect de ces règles
j'ai appris que 76 lettre de
licenciement avait été adressée ce matin
dont vater délégués du personnel il est
clair que cas par cas la situation de
ces travailleurs là sera examinée voilà
le rôle du ministre du travail
oui pour le reste tout le reste j'en
appelle une fois de plus à la à la
raison qui seule permet vous permettra
de trouver une solution à ce conflit il
appartient pas au gouvernement
le dic télé les conditions les les
moyens les les termes de cette solution
mais le thé une chose c'est qu'elle
passe forcément par l'ouverture d'un
dialogue qui est aussi nécessaire à la
vie de renault que la qualité totale de
ces deux produits est nécessaire à son
essor commercial
oui la vie de peugeot à la vie de
peugeot et certains en ce moment se pose
la question de savoir s'il ne faudrait
pas à votre question votre première
question était celle là s'il ne faudrait
pas que l'état intervienne davantage
je ne souhaite pas dans la solution des
conflits du travail une intervention
plus large de l'état au contraire je
souhaite le renforcement du dialogue et
je souhaite aussi le développement de la
politique contractuelle
monsieur soissons mais en refusant toute
augmentation de salaire est ce que
finalement jacques élevées nouveau rend
pas service puisqu'il évite un dérapage
une con
région un dérapage salariale dont il
faudrait pas résumée dans la politique
du gouvernement en fait que tel ou tel
patron refuse telle ou telle
augmentation de salaire c'est pas ça du
tout nous sommes sortis de l'austérité
et la rigueur que nous pouvons connaître
n'est pas l'austérité mais avec une
croissance de 3 points de trois points
et demi par an il faut que la rigueur
salariale se conjugue avec l'équité
qu'attendent les salariés et moi je dis
souvent ceci à tous les chefs
d'entreprise que je rentre dans mon
bureau
les travailleurs doivent participer à la
croissance retrouvée des entreprises
comme ils ont été associés aux efforts
de rigueur
mais dans le cas précis de peugeot vous
ne pouvez pas incité prendre des
initiatives pour inciter monsieur
qu'elle avait négociés
je n'ai aucun pouvoir pour inciter qui
que ce soit à la négociation j'appelle à
la négociation
je souhaitais pas provoquer telle ou
telle médiation je n'interviendrai que
leur fait que les fils du dialogue sont
renouer et que nous pourrons à ce moment
là arrivé à une à une solution mais ce
soit son âme ou encore le canard
enchaîné de demain publie la feuille
d'impôt de jacques calvet qui prouverait
qu'il a augmenté son propre salaire six
à sept fois plus vite que celui du
personnel votre votre réaction
de grâce ce n'est pas ainsi qu'on règle
orale le problème de peugeot 1 en france
chacun gagne de l'argent veux en gagner
davantage
et jusqu'à présent le secret fiscal et
conserver et doit être conservé monsieur
soissons merci oui je précise que
peugeot attaque le canard en justice la
publication de toute feuille d'impôts et
bien sûr illégal
les grévistes de peugeot commenté
évidemment à leur manière ces
révélations du canard d'autant plus que
demain mercredi et jours de paix et que
leur fiche vont accuser le coup de
quatre semaines de grève à mulhouse et à
sochaux on commence à déceler des signes
d'essoufflement il y aurait moins de
grévistes affirme la direction
c'est en tout cas toute une ville une
communauté entière qui vit au rythme du
conflit tant le système peugeot est
étroitement imbriqués à la vie locale
c'est ce qu'ont constaté là-bas maryse
mano et vincent maillard cet hôtel
appartient à peugeot 360 ouvriers vivent
ici
leur point commun ils travaillent tous
chez peugeot et ils sont célibataires
beaucoup de jeunes pour la plupart des
intérimaires ils ont normalement en tant
qu'intérimaire jure de rien dire
le règlement est strict on ne pardonne
pas aux fauteurs de troubles au lieu du
bordel quelques anciens ont vécu la plus
de 20 ans toute leur vie professionnelle
j'avais quand j'étais dans une petite
tuerie comme ça que vous tournez en rond
bah y'a des moments l'hôtel 1 et
condamné comme les cinq autres déjà
démoli le jour veut se débarrasser de
cette image trop paternaliste ceux qui
ont vécu là comme serge péters ne la
supporte puis l'avantagent pour peugeot
c'est d'avoir des célibataires sur place
de les garder autour de lusine juste les
à avoir les travailleurs sous la main
les loger qu'ils puissent se nourrir
puisque c'est quoi ça allait renouveler
leur force de travail pour retourner à
l'usiné lendemain pourtant serge péters
a quitté l'hôtel peugeot pour un hlm
peugeot même si ces logements
n'appartiennent pas directement au
groupe
c'est lui qui les attribue selon des
critères peugeot pour avoir le droit de
choisir son logement
bon bah il faut avoir de bonnes notes
ces bonnes notes dont les aucun pas en
militant dans un syndicat qui n'est pas
patronale militants cgt serge péters est
logique dans une banlieue peu prisés
d'autres ont plus de chance mais tous
dépendent de peu jour pour le travail
pour le logement pour les loisirs peut
jouer les sales traces parfois jusqu ici
oui toujours à propos du conflit peugeot
un sondage bien intéressant que publiera
demain la tribune de l'expansion et qui
montre que près de 60 % des patrons sont
pour la négociation pour l'ouverture
donc de discussions entre la direction
de peugeot et les syndicats mais en même
temps ils sont près de 54% a jugé que
monsieur calvé a bien géré jusqu'ici le
conflit social qui affecte son
entreprise automobile encore grandement
chez renault au mans et cléon ici à
cléon mouvement de grève aujourd'hui à
l'appel de la cgt de la cfdt la
direction souligne que les réunions se
poursuivent avec les syndicats sur le
nouvel accord d'entreprise
les grévistes eux ont décidé de
reconduire des arrêts de travail de deux
heures tous les deux jours da le
ministre soviétique des affaires
étrangères a dit oui à la proposition
américaine pour réduire et à tenir les
armes chimiques
l'assemblée générale des nations unies à
new york l'a applaudi à tout rompre
georges bortoli ces après-midi ou
nations unies le ministre soviétique
chez vernazza était d'excellente humeur
pour annoncer qu'il était d'accord avec
le président américain bush d'accord en
principe bien sûr et si tout va bien
pour arrêter la fabrication des armes
chimiques
mais monsieur chez vernaz et penche
aussi et même surtout aux autres armes
les armes nucléaires ils réclament une
fois de plus leur réduction en europe en
particulier et ce n'est peut-être pas
une coïncidence si pendant ce temps à
moscou monsieur gorbatchev présentait
aux députés du soviet suprême avec le
sourire un budget en fait à mr amer pour
les militaires puisqu'il prévoit une
réduction du budget de la défense de
près de 10%
conclusion si le gouvernement soviétique
et preneurs de désarmement ce n'est pas
seulement pour gagner la confiance de
l'occident c'est aussi parce que les
caisses sont vides à une forte majorité
le soviet suprême un an et demi c'est
d'évidence moscou a officiellement salué
aujourd'hui le retrait final des troupes
vietnamiennes du cambodge hun dernier
contingent de 26 mille hommes qui
occupaient le pays depuis dix ans qui
donc les lieux mais la guerre civile
à nouveau ce pays qui semble depuis tant
d'années abandonné par ses dieux jérôme
boni ça y est cette fois ci ils s'en
vont pour de bon les vingt-six mille
soldats vietnamiens encore basée au
cambodge sont en principe ce soir tous
rapatriés
mais y at il vraiment de quoi pavoiser
faute de règlement politique ces soldats
laissent derrière eux un pays au bord de
la guerre civile avril 75
les khmers rouges sont à quelques
kilomètres de la capitale cambodgienne
le maréchal lon nol tombeur du principal
ou cinq ans auparavant fui phnom penh
avec sa famille
il va être remplacé à la tête du
cambodge par polpot le chef des khmers
rouges
attaché au projet dément de restructurer
complètement la société cambodgienne
il se lance dans un véritable génocide
fin décembre 78 choisissant la période
des fêtes de fin d'année tout comme le
fera son grand frère soviétique un an
plus tard à kaboul hanoi envoie ses
troupes au cambodge
elle s'empare de phnom penh ville
fantôme vidée de ses habitants
exterminer ou envoyé aux travaux forcés
dans les champs la priorité des
vietnamiens va être pour justifier leur
intervention de révéler au monde toute
l'horreur du régime khmer rouge entre un
et deux millions de victimes sur une
population de 7 millions
l'occupant vietnamiens apporte du riz
mais aussi de la rééducation politique
janvier 82 l'assemblée générale de l'onu
demande au vietnam de retirer ses
troupes du cambodge
hanoi procède à grand renfort de
publicité à des opérations d'évacuation
dénoncés comme des simulacres par
l'opposition 30 juillet 89
après plusieurs tentatives infructueuses
depuis un an et demi les trois factions
de la guérilla cambodgienne rencontre à
nouveau le premier ministre une scène à
paris une scène restent farouchement
opposés à la participation des khmers
rouges au gouvernement de phnom penh
c'est un nouvel échec aujourd'hui après
le retrait du contingent vietnamiens les
réfugiés en thaïlande traverse le fleuve
frontière du mékong
mais vers quel avenir
vont ils servir de bouclier à l'avancé
des khmers rouges encore dirigé par paul
potes qui vient de lancer une vaste
offensive contre l'armée gouvernementale
faute de règlement politique la
population cambodgienne reste tenaillés
entre ces redoutables khmers rouges
soutenus par les chinois et le trop
puissant voisin vietnamien le patron des
12 chez les 23 pour la première fois
aujourd'hui jacques delors le président
de la commission de bruxelles s'est
adressé à strasbourg au conseil de
l'europe tout en insistant ce n'est pas
les images que vous voyez dernières mois
les images du conseil de l'europe donc
jacques delors tout en insistant sur la
spécificité de la démarche communautaire
qui essaient de l'intégration a plaidé
pour une europe plusieurs cercles qui
renforcerait la cohésion du continent
mais dans cette trempe là il ya aussi
des orphelins les pays de l'europe de
l'est est aujourd'hui la commission de
bruxelles a annoncé un véritable plan
daide à la pologne et à la hongrie
jacques delors bonsoir bonsoir plus de 4
milliards de francs pour ces deux pays
alors après beaucoup de discours ça
commence vraiment à devenir sérieux
est-ce que ce renforcement de l'aide
communautaire est lié dans votre esprit
dans l'esprit de la commission aux
progrès des réformes politiques et du
libéralisme économique dans ces pays
non nous n'entendons pas nous mêler des
affaires intérieures de la hongrie et de
la pologne et aux polonais et hongrois
de décider le régime politique qu'ils
veulent mais ce que l'on sait c'est que
la marche qu'ils ont entreprises vers la
démocratie le pluralisme ne pourra pas
continuer s'il n'ya pas modernisation de
leur économie
la situation est différente pour la
pologne c'est très grave et c'est très
urgent pour la hongrie
c'est important mais c'est moins urgents
dure des mois doit injecter sion
d'argent et puis une aide technique
oui mais dès le mois d'août nous avons
travailler pour envoyer une aide
alimentaire à la pologne puisque ce pays
connaît une rareté des produits
alimentaires des queues devant les
boutiques une inflation galopante et
nous allons continuer mais nous avons
déjà envoyé pour 2 milliards de francs
de produits alimentaires hélas ce que
nous avons fait après une concertation
entre 23 pays les 12 de la communauté
puce
onze autres pays démocratiques c'est que
nous avons mis au point les bases d'un
plan qui devrait permettre à la pologne
de faire repartir la machine économique
et à la hongrie de poursuivre son oeuvre
de modernisation économie jacques delors
pour la communauté et singulièrement
pour la commission que vous présidez
c'est quand même un nouveau champ
d'action est ce que ce n'est pas enfin
le le début d'une forme de coopération
politique bien sûr mais c'est surtout
très important parce que enfin et il a
fallu beaucoup d'efforts pour convaincre
tout le monde et aussi des conversations
très intéressante avec monsieur yahoo
les skis monsieur walesa et d'autres
enfin les européens vont s'occuper des
autres européens et vous voyez les
perspectives qu'il y avait derrière cela
si un jour on pouvait effacer yalta
c'est à dire la coupure de l'europe en
deux si l'on pouvait aider ces pays qui
sont de l'autre côté du rideau de fer a
retrouvé la prospérité économique et la
démocratie politique
quelle belle tâche enthousiasmante pour
les années à venir et en arrière fond
monsieur de l'or est ce que ce n'est pas
aussi une manière de freiner un peu
l'allemagne fédérale qui devient
véritablement le pivot de cette nouvelle
europe
la manne fédérale travaille au sein des
23 dans cet effort pour la pologne et la
hongrie
elle nous apporte d'ailleurs une
expertise car les par exemple mise
l'agriculture allemand connais très bien
l'agriculture polonaise et quant au
reste eh bien nous vivons peut-être un
nouveau monde avec la fin de la guerre
froide
vous comprendrez que cela cause beaucoup
d'émotion et beaucoup d'espoir chez les
allemands imaginer que les la france par
exemple se séparer de l'alsace et de la
lorraine
vous voyez ce que cela pourrait donner
par conséquent il faut comprendre les
allemands mais les allemands doivent
comprendre aussi que seule la poursuite
et même l'accélération de l'union
politique des douze permettra
un jour de rassembler les deux le peuple
les deux peuples divisée monsieur de
leurs je vous remercie
justement hier en allemagne fédérale
près de 8000 personnes ont réclamé à
leipzig des réformes et plus de libertés
louis carzou au moins 50 arrestations en
rda lors de la plus importante
manifestation d'opposants depuis 1953
les manifestants qui défilaient aux cris
de liberté égalité fraternité ont
réclamé la reconnaissance de
l'organisation dissidente forum nouveau
ce rassemblement avait lieu le jour même
du retour aux affaires d'eric honecker
le numéro un est allemand
pavlo bakoyannis député et porte parole
du parti conservateur assassiné devant
chez lui à athènes l'attentât condamné
par l'ensemble de la classe politique
grecque a été revendiqué par
l'organisation terroriste du 17 novembre
cet assassinat intervient un mois et
demi avant les prochaines élections
législatives en grèce
scènes d'émeutes à arnhem aux pays-bas
contre les trafiquants d'héroïne
quelques 2000 habitants de la petite
ville ont attaqué hier soir les
revendeurs et leurs lieux habituels de
vente la ville proche de la frontière
avec l'allemagne de l'ouest et le
théâtre de bagarre liée à la drogue
depuis six ans le ministre de la défense
annonce cette mesure pour les gendarmes
parmi lesquelles la création du conseil
de la gendarmerie
cette nouvelle structure devra établir
une plus grande concertation
les membres du conseil seront tirés au
sort parmi les gendarmes volontaires
les syndicats des personnels
pénitentiaires seront reçus par le garde
des sceaux lundi prochain cette annonce
intervient à la veille de nouvelles
actions de protestation dans les prisons
les gardiens réclament notamment
l'amélioration de leur régime de
retraite
légère hausse de 0 24% en clôture à la
bourse de paris le marché reste
perturbée par les problèmes monétaires
relative stabilité en revanche du dollar
à 6 francs 44,90 vite signer le
recyclage des médecins continuent aux
entretiens de bichat à paris
parmi les problèmes abordés aujourd'hui
celui des aides techniques qui
permettent le maintien à domicile de
malades mobilité réduite ou de handicap
et les médecins connaissent finalement
assez peu ces ustensiles qui sont bien
mal remboursés par la sécurité sociale
mais qui change la vie
jean daniel flaysakier claude sicard
jeanne serafini ne peut utiliser sa main
gauche conséquence d'une hémiplégie pour
elle couper la viande et chaque jour une
épreuve mais grâce à la rééducation elle
a découvert usage de petits ustensiles
qu'on appelle des aides techniques tel
ce plateau antidérapant et quand cela ne
suffit pas on peut même ajouter ce que
l'on appelle un couteau fourchette
un véritable petit hachoir un objet
facilement transportable qu'on peut
emporter chez des années ou encore au
restaurant les petites astuces sont
multiples ainsi avec un manche en de
mousse une main déformé par l'arthrite
peut de nouveau tenir une fourchette
et pas besoin d'être fakir pour utiliser
cette planche à clous qui permet de
couper ou des peluches et un fruit ou un
légume
épluchez de non seulement c'est aussi
possible avec un couteau économe fixé
sur un petit et eaux en bord de table
mais le fin du fin c'est quand même ce
copier qui non seulement adhère à la
table mais aussi à des rats l'oeuf ce
qui permet de séparer le jaune du blanc
est toujours d'une seule main le
problème avec ces aides techniques c'est
qu'elles sont parfois cher est rarement
remboursés par la sécurité sociale ce
qui est bien dommage car lorsqu'on a par
exemple le dos bloqué qu'on ne peut pas
se baisser
une pince ramasse objets comme celle ci
est bien utile elle permet même
d'attraper des objets aussi fin qu'un
ticket de bus ou de métro
la seule difficulté ensuite c'est de
trouver un transport en commun
accessible aux handicapés
certains de ces objets je connais bien
des maladroits qui pourrait s'en servir
utilement son histoire mérite une
nouvelle ou plutôt un roman fleuve il a
63 ans
depuis ce matin il est en liberté il a
passé en prison 41 ans six mois et sept
jours
victor deuil dealer était l'un des plus
ancien prisonnier de france son histoire
celle d'un homme brave qui n'a pas
compris les contradictions de l'histoire
isabelle staes et philipp etter l'ont
retrouvé à 64 ans 8h02 l'ida réapprend à
vivre libres 1 à 7 heures ce matin il a
quitté la centrale de poissy
cela faisait 40 ans qui ne s'était pas
promener le long des quais en revivant
arrivé un peu par victor à 21 ans
lorsqu'ils entrent pour la première fois
en prison polonais d'origine résistant
au sein des ftp dénoncés et déportés à
son retour des camps il cherche à se
venger pour deux braquages chez ceux qui
l'ont donné il est condamné à 20 ans de
travaux forcés puis c'est l'engrenage
récidive tentative d'évasion
victor ne connaît que la prison comme on
tient couac on fera de proches
ben el harrach
sinon il vaut mieux suicide
moi j'ai surtout peur que donne pas mais
parce que j'aurai fait tout ce qu'elle
est ce qu'elle a souffert
votre père mon père aimant 20 pages que
vient 90 pour votre tentative d'évasion
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
maintenant vous avez des projets non
votre avenir vous imaginez pour l'avenir
il est d'ailleurs moins depuis quarante
ans après victor ne comprend toujours
pas pourquoi des français l'ont dénoncé
aux allemands sa première permission
c'était il ya quinze jours il est allé
embrasser sa mère il ne l'avait pas vu
depuis 13 ans mais aujourd'hui il ne
peut la rejoindre dans son village natal
en meurthe et moselle
il est interdit de séjour du coq à l'âne
si l'on peut dire une nomination dans
l'audiovisuel hervé bourges déjà
directeur général de radio monte carlo
deviendra officiellement demeure
président de la sofirad la société qui
gère les participations de l'état dans
l'audiovisuel en france et à l'étranger
un mot rapide de football encore son
show s'est qualifié pour le 2e tour de
la coupe de l'uefa en battant sans
chicane et le club luxembourgeois de
hèches 5 1 0 voilà et puis je reçois à
l'instant l'ordre d'arrivée de la course
de vincennes sur lequel se jouait le
tiercé et le quinté plus le quinté plus
vous le voyez dans l'ordre le neuf le 3
le 2 le 16 et le 18 pour le tiercé bien
sûr les trois premiers chevaux le neuf
le 3 et le 2 mai je ne prenais pas
encore les rapports henri sannier pourra
vous les donner dans le dernier journal
vers 23h45 voilà dans un instant sophie
davant vous parlera du tente de bain
très bonne soirée
admirateur